Let's say I've got some linear
transformation T that is a
mapping from Rn to Rn.
So if this is its domain, which
is just Rn, then its
codomain is also Rn.
If you give me some vector in
our domain, let's call that
vector x, then T will map it
to some other member of Rn,
which is also the codomain.
So it'll map it over here.
We could call that the mapping
of T, or the mapping
of x, or T of x.
Since T is a linear
transformation, we know that
the mapping of x to its codomain
is equivalent to x
being multiplied by
some matrix A.
So we know that this thing right
here is equal to some
matrix A times x.
You've seen all of this
multiple, multiple times.
Just to make sure we understand
the wording
properly, we said we've used
the word that A is the-- we
could either call it the matrix
for T, or let's say
it's the transformation
matrix for T.
Now, in the last couple of
videos, we've learned that the
same vector can be represented
in different ways.
It can be represented in
different coordinate systems.
When I just write the vector x
like that, we just assume that
it's being represented in
standard coordinates, or it's
being represented with respect
to the standard basis.
So let's be a little bit
more particular.
This A is the transformation
for T only when x is
represented in standard
coordinates, or only when x is
written in coordinates with
respect to the standard basis.
So let me write a little
qualifier here.
A is the transformation matrix
for T with respect to the
standard basis.
I never wrote this
blue part before.
I never even said this blue part
before, because the only
coordinate system we were
dealing with was the standard
coordinate system or the
coordinates with respect to
the standard basis.
But now we know that there are
multiple coordinate systems.
There are multiple ways to
represent this vector.
represent that vector, because
Rn has multiple spanning
bases.
There are multiple bases that
can represent Rn, and each of
those bases can generate a
coordinate system where you
can represent any vector in Rn
with coordinates with respect
to any of those bases.
So that last part I said was a
bit of a mouthful, so let me
make it a little bit
more concrete.
Let's say that I have some basis
B that's made up of n--
it has to be linearly
independent.
That's the definition of a
basis-- of n vectors v1, v2,
all the way to vn.
Now, these are n linearly
independent vectors.
Each of these are
members of Rn.
So B is a basis for Rn, which is
just another way of saying
that all of these vectors are
linearly independent and any
vector in Rn can be represented
as a linear
combination of these guys, which
is another way of saying
that any vector in Rn can be
represented with coordinates
with respect to this
basis right there.
So the same vector x,
I'm going to put
the same dot here.
When we represent it in standard
coordinates, it's
just going to be that right
there, that vector x.
But what if we want to represent
it in coordinates
with respect to this
new basis?
Well, then that same vector
x will look like this.
We would denote it by this.
The same vector can be
represented with respect to
this basis.
This could be some set
of coordinates.
This would be some other set of
coordinates, but it's still
representing the same basis.
Likewise, this vector right
here, that vector right there,
is also in Rn.
So it can be represented by
some linear combination of
these guys, or you can represent
it with coordinates
with respect to this basis.
So that same point right there,
I could represent it.
So that point is this.
But I could represent it with
coordinates with respect to my
basis just like that.
So this is an interesting
question.
This should maybe bring
an interesting
question into your brain.
If I start off with something
that's in standard
coordinates, and I apply the
transformation T-- that's like
applying this matrix A to it or
multiplying that thing in
standard coordinates times the
matrix A-- I then get the
mapping of T in standard
coordinates.
Now, what if I start off with
that thing in nonstandard
coordinates if I have
coordinates with respect to
this other basis here?
Well, T should still
map it to this guy.
The transformation, no matter
what, should always map from
that dot to that dot.
It shouldn't care what
your coordinates are.
So T should still map to
that same exact point.
T should still be a linear
transformation.
It can map from x to T of x, but
that's the same thing as
mapping from this kind of way
of labeling x to this way of
labeling x.
So we could say maybe this guy
right here could be some other
matrix times this
guy over here.
So let me write this
over here.
These are just different
coordinate systems. I
shouldn't just even say maybe.
This guy should be able
to be represented.
So if I represent the mapping
of x in our codomain in
coordinates with respect to B--
so that's what that guy is
right there-- so if I want to
represent that dot with this
other coordinate system,
coordinates with respect to
this basis, it should be
equal to the product
of some other matrix.
Let me call that
other matrix D.
Some other matrix D times this
representation of x times the
coordinates of x with respect
to my alternate nonstandard
coordinate system.
I should be able to find some
matrix D that does this.
Then we would say that D is the
transformation matrix for T.
A assumes that you have x in
terms of standard coordinates.
Now D assumes that you have x in
coordinates with respect to
this basis, so with respect
to the basis B.
There's no reason why we
shouldn't be able to do this.
These things are just different
ways of representing
the exact same vector,
the exact same
dot in our sets here.
So if I represent it one way,
the standard way, I multiply
by A, and I get Ax.
If I represent it in nonstandard
coordinates, I
should be able to multiply it
by some other matrix and get
another nonstandard coordinate
representation of what
it gets mapped to.
So let's see if we can find
some relation between
D and between A.
So we learned a couple of videos
ago that there's a
change of basis matrix that we
can generate from this basis.
It's pretty easy to generate.
The change of basis matrix is
just a matrix whose columns
are these basis vectors, so
v1, v2-- I shouldn't put a
comma there.
These are just the columns--
v2 all the way to vn.
This is an n-by-n matrix.
Each of these guys are members
of Rn and we have n of them.
This is an n-by-n matrix where
all of the columns are
linearly independent, so we
know that C is invertible.
These are column vectors
right here.
So we know that C
is invertible.
We learned in the last two or
three videos that if we have
some vector x, and it's being
represented by coordinates
with respect to our basis B, we
can just multiply that by
C, and we'll get our vector x.
This essentially will tell us
the linear combination of
these guys that'll get us x.
Since C is invertible, we also
saw that if we have the
standard format for x, or the
standard coordinates for x, we
can multiply that
by C inverse.
That will get us the coordinates
for x with respect
to the basis B.
These two things, if you just
multiply both sides of this
equation-- let me do it in a
different color-- if you just
multiply both sides of this
equation by C inverse on the
left-hand side, you're
going to get this
equation right there.
Now given that, let's
see if we can find
some type of relation.
Let's see what D times
xB is equal to.
So let's say if we take D times
xB, so this thing right
here should be equal to D times
the representation or
the coordinates of x with
respect to the basis B.
That's what we're claiming.
We're saying that this guy
is equal to D times the
representation of x with respect
to the coordinates
with respect to the basis B.
Let me write all of this down.
I'll do it right here, because I
think it's nice to have this
graphic up here.
So we can say that D times
xB is equal to
this thing right here.
It's the same thing as the
transformation of x
represented in coordinates with
respect to B, or in these
nonstandard coordinates.
So it's equal to the
transformation of x
represented in this coordinate
system, represented in
coordinates with respect to B.
We see that right there.
But what is the transformation
of x?
That's the same thing
as A times x.
That's kind of the standard
transformation if x was
represented in standard
coordinates.
So this is equal to x in
standard coordinates
times the matrix A.
Then that will get us to this
dot in standard coordinates,
but then we want to convert
it to these nonstandard
coordinates just like that.
Now, if we have this, how can
we just figure out what the
vector Ax should look like?
What this vector should
look like?
Well, we can look at this
equation right here.
We have this.
This is the same
thing as this.
Actually.
we want to go the other way.
We have this.
We have that right there.
That's this right there.
We want to get just this dot
represented in regular
standard coordinates.
So what do we do?
We multiply it by C.
Let me write it this way.
If we multiply both sides
of this equation times
C, what do we get?
We get this right here.
Actually, no.
I was looking at the right
equation the first time.
We have this right here, which
is the same-- first intuition
is always right.
We have this, which is the same
thing as this right here.
So this can be rewritten.
This thing can be rewritten
as C inverse-- we
don't have an x here.
We have an Ax here, so
C inverse times Ax.
The vector Ax represented in
these nonstandard coordinates
is the same thing as multiplying
the inverse of our
change of basis matrix
times the vector Ax.
If I have my vector Ax and I
multiply it times the inverse
of the change of basis matrix,
I will then have a
representation of the vector
Ax in my nonstandard basis.
Now, what is the vector
x equal to?
Well, the vector x is equal to
our change of basis matrix
times x represented in these
nonstandard coordinates.
So this is going to be equal to
C inverse A times x. x is
just the same thing as C.
x is just C times our
nonstandard coordinates for x,
just like that.
Let me summarize it, just
because I waffled a little bit
on this point right there
just because I got
a little bit confused.
If I start off with the
nonstandard representation of
x, or x in coordinates
with respect to B, I
multiply them times D.
So if I start with this, I
multiply them times D, I get
to that point right there.
So this right there is
the same thing as
this point right there.
That point right there should
be the nonstandard
representation of the
transformation of x, or the
coordinates of the
transformation of x with
respect to B.
Now, the transformation of
x, if x is in standard
coordinates, is just
A times x.
So this is just A times x.
But I want to represent it in
these nonstandard coordinates.
Now, A times x in nonstandard
coordinates is the same thing
as C inverse times A times x, if
you think this is the same
thing as this.
So if you have this and you
want to represent it in
nonstandard coordinates, you
multiply it by C inverse, so
then you'll get that
representation in nonstandard
coordinates.
Then finally, we say look, x is
the same thing as C times
the nonstandard coordinate
representation of x.
So we can replace x with
that right there.
So the big takeaway here is that
D times the coordinates
of x with respect to the basis
B is equal to C inverse A
times C times the coordinates
of x with respect
to the basis B.
So D must be equal
to C inverse AC.
So if D is the transformation
matrix for T with respect to
the basis B-- and let me write
here-- and C is the change of
basis matrix for B-- let me
write that down, might as well
because this is our big
takeaway-- and A is the
transformation-- I'll write it
in shorthand-- matrix for T
with respect to the standard
basis, then we can say-- this
is the big takeaway-- that D,
our matrix D, is equal to C
inverse times A times C.
That's our big takeaway from
this video, which is really
interesting.
I don't want you to
lose this point.
We now understand that A is
just for a certain set of
coordinates.
But there's arbitrary different
bases that we can
use to represent Rn, so we can
have different matrices that
represent the linear
transformation under different
coordinate systems. If we want
to figure out those different
matrices for different
coordinate systems, we can
essentially just construct the
change of basis matrix for the
coordinate system we care about,
and then generate our
new transformation matrix with
respect to the new basis by
just applying this result.